qu'ils oublient femmes viennent tout
arrive en parle maintenant pour aller
seul un gros lapin car les marins de la
femme comme mondiale et frisés ça ne pas
payer le coiffeur ni qu'il se soignait
pour un puncheur chez elle dans un
produit tout alors fait alors quand une
frise n'a pas paraître prendre ta vu un
coup de queue de vache bardé de bouche
de vastes comme on dit chez nous le
maire de bages ben la femme si elle
s'est fait le prisé par exemple hier un
bain demain à l'écouté glace quoi on a
trop manger deux pommes de terre pour
arriver au but où c'est qu'on est arrivé
mais se priver des os coiffées
puisqu'ils sont six prix votre toilette
on est habillé avec des habits gooden de
la ville que les gens veulent plus
porteurs de santo lui eut d'ailleurs son
d'arrêt pour les moyens j'estime une
chose que si on avait les moyens la
possibilité d'aller bouffer entre de
l'hôtel sa relaxe serait quand même ma
femme qu'il n'y a pas de problème à
aller aux antilles petit moment de
respirer commenté vous n'allez jamais
jamais je mets à jamais on n'a pas les
moyens de se payer l'hôtel moi-même et
mon restaurant jamais mais non même pas